here's what would happen if you lit a  match on Jupiter with no solid surface  Jupiter is almost entirely gaseous but  before you go ahead and strike that  match you need to remember fire needs  oxygen  without any Oxygen in Jupiter's  atmosphere it would be impossible for  the planet to erupt in Flames not only  that but lighting your match would be  difficult since without oxygen the  ignition of a match just wouldn't happen  instead you'd need to reinvent the  matchbox in a way that it doesn't need  external oxygen in the atmosphere and  then you'd need to gather a lot of  oxygen because in order for this  hydrogen giant to combust you'd need  about half as much oxygen present in the  atmosphere as there is hydrogen but in  reality there just isn't enough oxygen  in the entire solar system for this to  happen so sorry to disappoint you but  Jupiter won't be erupting in Flames  anytime soon because